foreign
music
[Music]
the new facts are your friends segments
it's a couple of days after Thanksgiving
and some of you are still sitting there
in shock that you just experienced the
holiday season that you experienced
the uh Thanksgiving at your in-laws
house or at your parents house or you
just stared at your significant other
and thought this is my life this is this
is my life or your kids said that thing
at Thanksgiving dinner and you thought
well I'm gonna go bury myself in the
backyard
um
or
you were at your grandma's house
and your son came out and you asked him
hey uh did you change your underwear
after you just took your shower
and he said something like I haven't
changed it in four days why would I
change it now and you think I don't like
to I don't I don't like the holidays
here we are now
today's facts of your friends is going
to be around a segment I mean around
something I get asked all the time
direct messages people email into the
show
it's the idea of choosing guilt over
resentment
you just left Thanksgiving and let's be
honest for many of you for millions of
you it was awesome it was a great time
with friends it was a great time with
family it was good
some of you just took a dive and when
somebody started talking politics did
you vote who'd you vote for I you were
just like all right I'm gonna just Jesus
take the wheel and others of you had a
rough go of it it was a long ride in the
car on the way there it was a long run
on the way back you didn't sleep you
can't go to the bathroom other people's
homes whatever the thing was right
and now you're already making plans for
what Christmas is going to look like the
Christmas holidays the New Year's
holidays what are we going to go
somewhere we're going to not go anywhere
who's coming to our house
what are we gonna buy Grandma already
buys all this stuff mom and dad buy
every sister's gonna
what are we gonna do we're gonna choose
guilt over resentment all right so on
today's facts of your friends guilt over
resentment here's what it looks like all
right guilt I took some notes Here
guilt is the frustration or anger that I
feel
when I violate my own core values even
if my if my core values are wrong if
they're dumb like one of my core values
used to be I will make sure everybody
else is is okay before me
and what that often meant was I ended up
agreeing to conversations about stupid
stuff that I didn't care about or that I
abjectly disagreed with
um my one of my uh core values used to
be nobody's gonna disrespect me and so I
spent a whole bunch of useless energy
trying to make sure everybody else
recognized how important I was and how
good I was and how smart I was and how
accomplished I was completely not a
wasted time
and if I didn't get my hey did you hear
that I got another degree I won this
leadership award here I got into Harvard
but whatever the thing was I'd feel
guilty about it I should have told him I
shouldn't have said that I said too much
oh my goodness Guild kill Gil can also
be a value that's really important I
stole something and I feel guilty about
it I swore at my kid and I I yelled at
my kid and I feel guilty about that
that's not who I want to be it's not who
I am and I did that thing
um I snapped at my wife I showed up late
to work again like I feel guilty it
violates a core value here right so
guilt is when you do something that
violates your core value feel guilty
about it
Court one of your core values
resentment on the other hand is the
jealousy I feel when someone has power
over me that I've even either conceited
I gave it away to him or they took it
from me because they're in a position of
power they've got bigger muscles than me
they're stronger than me I'm staying in
their house
they're paying my car insurance they
helped out with my down payment on my
house and they've been holding over my
head for 10 years whatever the thing is
Right resentment is about jealousy brene
Brown has an incredible discussion about
this if you want to go further down the
rabbit hole in this
um that we all thought resentment was
about rage was about anger and actually
it's about jealousy
that you have that kind of power over me
and here's the deal guilt is healthy I
think guilt is healthy I think it's an
evolutionary
um emotion right it's important for our
bodies to feel guilty when we violate
core values they're going to ultimately
separate us from our gang from our
people from our tribe from our community
from our spouses from our kids it's
important that our body has a reaction
to that so we stop the behavior and then
we do the necessary things we ask for
forgiveness we say we're sorry we bridge
the gap or we put up boundaries whatever
we got to do to become right with
ourselves and right with our community
again guilt I think on the whole is good
when you put guilt in your backpack and
you choose to carry it you go from I did
a dumb thing to I am a dumb thing right
that's shame
guilt in and of itself is good
resentment
is not
resentment is the death of almost every
relationship
resentment is Ash after a fire
right
um
choosing guilt over resentment is a
powerful way to reclaim your life
when somebody challenges your boundaries
you're gonna be uncomfortable you're
going to get frustrated you're going to
get annoyed I said we're not spending
more than a hundred dollars on all of
Christmas gifts and you went and bought
a 500 Xbox for one kid and Nike shoes
for another kid
man somebody challenged your boundaries
they ran right over them to see if
they're if they were true they're gonna
hold
and you take the gifts and you put them
back in the package and you set them on
the counter and say we are not taking
these gifts
thank you for
um loving our kids but we all agreed
we're not doing this for our kids
they've got enough stuff at the house
um and we agreed on that you're gonna
feel so guilty and they're gonna make
you feel guilty
they're gonna make you feel guilty
that's okay
the alternative is resentment taking
them the whole way home seething
they got more power over my kids than I
do
they've got more influence and sway
because I said nothing I just gave it
away or I had to take this because I
wasn't safe
it's resentment
and so here let's bring this home really
close let's take husbands and wives
husband comes in and says hey every
Christmas we're going to Grandma's house
and you spouse wife you know that at
Grandma's house you always end up in the
kitchen with the four other women
and they're always talking about how
much their husbands are lame and you
actually like yours
in one year you spoke up and it's like I
actually like him and everybody laughed
at you rolled their eyes
somebody asked you why your jeans were
so small
it made fun of your shirt
they asked you oh did you start going to
Great Clips for your hair again they
just you're tired of it
they ask you why you let your kids talk
that way
why they don't have such some app on
their phone and you say we don't do
phones and like oh I got your kid the
new iPhone
you're just done you're done
and here's what you can do
you can sit down with your husband well
in advance and say listen
this year
I don't want to miss the holidays again
I show up in body but I miss him in
spirit I'm not the mom I want to be I'm
not the wife I want to be I'm not the me
I want to be
so I'm asking you to join me in
recreating a new holiday memory and we
let our families know that this year
we're not going to travel this year
we're going to do things our Christmas
at home
and the moment you say those words
you're going to feel guilty because you
know your husband likes going home
because he gets to go hunt with the guys
they all go out they all hang out and
have a good time whatever and he's not
stuck at home doing bad times doing
morning times listening to all the
reasons he's a failure
you're gonna feel guilty
and that's better than yet again getting
in the car seething the whole week
before
seething the whole way there snapping at
your little ones being cold being
frustrated turning the music up a little
bit louder turning your headphones up a
little bit louder and when he reaches
over to connect with you you rip one of
the headphones out and you go what what
it's not about him that's you
that's the jealousy
somebody else has control over your life
so this year
whenever you start to think I don't want
to do this or I don't want to go I don't
want to be a part of this
think about choosing guilt over
resentment
choose feeling guilty and having
boundaries choose feeling guilty and
having peace choose feeling guilty
over resentment anger rage jealousy
frustration
because your kids are going to look back
and remember not what you said but how
you made them feel as the old quote goes
and they're going to remember whether
the holidays were a season of warmth
a season of laughter and joy or a season
of great tension
they are going to make up their own
stories as to why it was tense and most
kids most of the time
put them at the center of that story
that they were doing something wrong
husbands and wives do it to each other
too
so let's choose honesty let's choose
openness
let's choose boundaries let's choose
what if we
what if we designed
the perfect Christmas and we reverse
engineered it and said how close can we
get to that
not we have to go do these five things
we have to spend this much money we have
to travel this far
what if we didn't do that this time
what if we said here's what would be the
best holidays for us this season let's
reverse engineer and build that and it
might include family and it might not
this year and that's okay you still love
them still love them
but not this year this year we're gonna
lay low we're gonna hang out we're gonna
do us stuff
we're gonna go just play in a hotel pool
kids will think that's more fun than
Xbox anyway
choose guilt over resentment
Kelly does that cover it
sounds good love it
all right good that's facts of your
friends volume what
111.